[Musik]
live aus köln
der presseclub mit allen
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem
presseclub am sonntag heute wollen wir
uns mit den wirtschaftlichen folgen des
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine hier bei
uns im land beschäftigen die preise für
lebensmittel werden steigen in der
nächsten woche das haben bereits mehrere
handelsketten angekündigt und grund für
diese preistreiberei ist unter anderem
die schon lange hohen energiekosten und
der krieg in der ukraine
beide hängen natürlich unmittelbar
miteinander zusammen denn wie abhängig
wir von russischen energielieferungen
also gas und öl sind das hat uns der
russische präsident diese woche wieder
spüren lassen als er gesagt hat in
zukunft werden diese energielieferung
nur noch in rubel akzeptiert werden
deutschland hat das zurückgewiesen und
besteht darauf weiterhin in euro zu
bezahlen doch andere länder so die
baltischen staaten estland lettland und
litauen die reagieren jetzt proaktiv sie
haben angekündigt keine weiteren
gasimporte aus russland mehr abzufordern
wäre das auch ein weg für deutschland
[Musik]
energie als politische waffe die einen
fordern jetzt ein radikales energie
embargo um den russischen krieg nicht
weiter zu finanzieren
ein russisches gas embargo warnen andere
bedeute einen wirtschaftskollaps in
deutschland klar ist aber das ist für
uns keine form von politischer
erpressung geben kann verträge werden so
erfüllt wie sie geschlossen worden sind
insbesondere wollen wir keine weiteren
beiträge leisten und putins kriegskasse
zu füllen werde nicht gezahlt droht
putin könnte der gashahn zugedreht
werden der griechische wenn diese
zahlungen nicht erfolgen werden wir das
als vertragsbruch werten mit allen
nötigen konsequenzen
das lässt wirtschaftsminister habeck hat
für deutschland den gas notfallplan
ausgerufen aus sorge um einen
lieferstopp schon jetzt hat den krieg
folgen für die wirtschaft es ist ein
externer schock der auf das land kommt
und das muss man so klar sagen wir
werden dadurch ärmer werden
und genau das ist das thema unseres
presseclubs heute ohne putins öl und gas
welche folgen drohen und ich freue mich
auf diese runde mit der ich das thema
diskutieren möchte petra pinzler sie ist
korrespondentin im hauptstadtbüro der
zeit herzlich willkommen auch an kerstin
münstermann sie leitet die
parlamentsredaktion in berlin für die
rheinische post herzlich willkommen
michael bauchmüller er ist korrespondent
aus dem parlamentsbüro in berlin der
süddeutschen zeitung und ich heiße klaus
stratmann willkommen erst
chefkorrespondent für klima und energie
beim handelsblatt schön dass sie alle
hier sind und auch in den sozialen
netzwerken können sie sich an unserer
diskussion beteiligen sie tun das jetzt
schon rege es ist ein thema was sie
öffentlich offensichtlich alle direkt
angeht ich möchte gerne mit herrn
stratmann beginnen wir rätseln ja jetzt
seit ein paar tagen schon was hat es
denn mit dieser ankündigung auf sich
putin sagt nur noch in ruhe bezahlen es
gibt ein dekret und gleichzeitig hat er
unseren kanzler versichert dass man
weiter in euro bezahlen dürfe was gilt
denn jetzt was wissen sie darüber ja
also herr putin ist es gelungen
verunsicherung zu schüren so viel ist
schon mal klar
es ist aber auch so dass bis jetzt alles
noch so funktioniert wie bislang also
stand gestern stand heute morgen fließt
das gas aber ob das so bleibt ist offen
es scheint so zu sein dass es einen
modus geben wird wie man dieses problem
dass putin erzeugt hat umschifft es wird
ein konto geben wo man ein euro einzahlt
und ein weiteres wo in rubel dann
ausgezahlt werden ja das sind alles
buchhalter tricks die niemandem helfen
und man versteht auch nicht so recht was
damit bezweckt werden soll es wurde
verhinderte beitrag schon deutlich die
deutsche seite die europäer die g7
staaten haben klar gesagt dass sie sich
daran halten was in den verträgen steht
und das ist
eben es wird bezahlt in euro oder dollar
einsatz noch dazu
die stunde der wahrheit kommt erst
später denn das was bis ende märz
beispielsweise geliefert wurde wird erst
mitte april bezahlt das ist in den
meisten verträgen so geregelt dass heißt
wie die sache wirklich ausgeht kann man
heute noch gar nicht sagen auch wenn im
moment noch das gas fließt also die
verunsicherung geht weiter und die
unternehmen unternehmen die damit
umgehen müssen wissen auch alle noch
nicht so recht wie es ausgeht ok danke
für diese klarheit in der unklarheit
vielleicht in diesem zusammenhang gerne
noch eine frage an sie es ist ja am
selben tag wo das dekret erlassen wurde
haben wir auch erfahren dass gazprom
sich von seiner deutschen tochter
gazprom germania trend dass es die
betreiberfirma hier eben deutschland was
heißt das denn in dem zusammenhang da
gibt es eine theorie die ich für sehr
nachvollziehbar halte es gibt innerhalb
der bundesregierung diskussion darüber
gazprom germania zumindest den speicher
teil dieses unternehmens zu enteignen
das wird durchgespielt das ist kein
beschluss oder es ist aber es steht im
raum und möglicherweise ist gazprom in
russland also der mutterkonzern diesem
schritt damit zuvor gekommen wie das
weitergeht wissen wir auch im moment
noch nicht möglicherweise das ist eine
theorie über die im moment noch geredet
wird
schaltet gazprom ein strohmann ein und
übergibt das unternehmen gazprom
germania in denen aber das ist völlig
unklar also auch da sind die
fragezeichen groß und man merkt auch wie
offen das zerwürfnis in dieser frage
zwischen der bundesregierung und
russland mittlerweile ist ein satz noch
die es gibt noch einen weiteren
kandidaten der große probleme hat das
ist der der
ölkonzern rosneft rosneft deutschland
für die öl und benzin und kerosin
versorgung großer teile ostdeutschlands
enorm wichtig auch diese unternehmen ist
in schwierigkeiten weil niemand mehr mit
diesem unternehmen zu tun haben will
auch da muss man sich möglicherweise
darüber unterhalten ob der staat ob die
bundesregierung da einspringt und hilft
widerwillig bei rosneft ohne dass wir
jetzt in so eine detail diskussion
eintreten wollen aber da gibt es ja auch
eine bewegung sag ich mal kurz vor dem
krieg wurde gestattet dass die
anteilseigner da deutlich erhöhen
sollten das ist jetzt aber erstmal
wieder gestoppt also haben wir da eine
gegenteilige bewegung das eigentlich der
russische staat stärker auftreten will
bei rosneft wollte muss man sagen das
ist für die nächsten jahre und
wahrscheinlich auch jahrzehnte passe
aber das war ein prozess über jahre den
man auch bei gazprom germania und bei
rosneft feststellen konnte die russin
die russische seite wollte aktiver
werden auf dem deutschen markt und hat
zum beispiel im gasgeschäft ja auch die
ganze prozesskette mittlerweile
abgebildet was ich höre ist dass da im
moment viel rückabgewickelt wird schon
allein weil diese unternehmen
selbst wenn sie nicht direkt von den
sanktionen betroffen sind aber doch
viele banken mit denen einfach nicht
mehr umgehen wollen also viele der
verpflichtungen die wir mit russland
hatten politisch und ökonomisch in den
letzten jahren die werden jetzt
aufgelösten das heißt wir stellen auf
der einen seite fest dass also
letztendlich eine trennung zwischen dem
russischen mutter unternehmen sei es
jetzt gazprom rosneft ist und den
unternehmen in deutschland gleichzeitig
wissen wir nicht wie lange putin uns
noch gas liefern wird dh diese
verunsicherung ist da dann kommen wir
doch jetzt mal zu dem thema die
baltischen staaten machen es jetzt vor
so nach dem motto wir warten nicht mehr
sondern wir entscheiden aktiv und staat
zu trennen möchte einen nutzer hier an
der stelle
einbinden der dazu sehr konkret gefragt
hat matthias rehfeld auf twitter was ist
denn die einschätzung der runde die
folgen eines gaslieferstopps und oder
eines embargos wenn wir es aussprechen
würden reicht von katastrophal sagt der
basf-chef bis nicht so schlimm oder
händelbar sagen ökonomische modelle wo
liegt denn die wahrheit verbraucht man
die wahrheit werden wir wahrscheinlich
erst dann sehen wenn dieser fall
eintritt also bei den baltischen staaten
haben wir es mit staaten zu tun die
nicht annähernd so stark von gas
abhängen wie deutschland und die sich
auch in der vergangenheit mit einem
eigenen lng terminal schon auf den fall
vorbereitet haben die haben auch sehr
gut gefüllte speicher im augenblick also
da fällt es relativ leicht wenn wir uns
das vorstellen zu deutschland das wir
also im grunde die pipelines abdrehen
und kein russisches gas mehr nach
deutschland lassen dann heißt das dass
dieses gas physisch fehlt das kann nicht
auf anderen wegen einfach so dann in den
in den weltmarkt fließen das heißt die
preise für gas werden durch die decke
gehen also da wird das was wir bisher
erlebt haben
wirklich ein
kleiner vorgeschmack gewesen sein und
diese konsequenzen die müssen wir uns
glaube ich sehr sehr genau vor augen
führen es ist ganz klar der moralische
druck der wird mit jedem neuen bericht
aus der ukraine steigen und mit den
bildern die wir eben auch gesehen haben
natürlich wünschen wir uns alle dass wir
putin sofort im grunde alles abschneiden
womit er geld verdienen kann aber wir
müssen beim thema gas müssen wir uns
wirklich der realität stellen dass das
eine wirtschaftskrise auslösen wird die
wir dass wir die nach dem krieg und ich
glaube das ist auch die die größte
problematik gerade der ampel regierung
also wir hören ja dauernd
wirtschaftsminister haarweg heute
finanzminister christian lindner in
einem aktuellen interview diese
zerrissenheit zwischen der moral auf der
einen und den wirklich wirklich ganz
tiefen befürchtungen also sowohl aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium als auch aus dem
finanzministerium wird gewarnt
vielleicht nicht ganz so wie der
basf-chef das getan hat aber wenn man
mal rein hört es sind ja nicht nur die
unternehmen es ist ja auch die die
gewerkschaften die vor massiven
arbeitsplatz
und da eine gratwanderung zu finden wie
gehe ich mit den bildern aus diesem
schrecklichen krieg um und gleichzeitig
der stabilität dieses landes was die
wirtschaft angeht und auch die
gesellschaft ist glaube ich eine
wirkliche nagelprobe die große
schwierigkeit ist dass wir einfach die
folgen schlicht nicht prognostizieren
können es gibt ja tatsächlich ökonomen
die gesagt haben das ist zu schaffen
weil das sozialprodukt zwar sinken wird
aber nicht katastrophal
ich glaube das problem ist dass wir das
makroökonom so ein bisschen es ist wie
eine wettervorhersage für ganz
deutschland wo man sagt das wetter wird
15 grad warm das kann aber eben sein
dass es dann im norden null grad ist im
süden 30 grad und die ökonomischen
folgen die wir in bestimmten regionen
haben werden also beispielsweise wenn
das öl nicht mehr nach schwedt kommt
dann der kollege hat eben angesprochen
dann fliegt in berlin kein flugzeug mehr
jetzt kann man sagen flugzeug fliegen
soll man sowieso nicht mehr so viel aber
es ist nur ein beispiel von denen von
den folgen die glaube ich die regierung
jetzt erst anfängt überhaupt zu
herauszufinden weil wir so komplizierte
lieferketten haben ja nicht nur beim öl
sondern beim gas viel mehr und das gas
abgestellt wird um nur ein beispiel zu
nennen dann beispielsweise bei basf dann
kann kein ammoniak mehr produziert
werden wenn kein ammoniak mehr
produziert werden kann dann haben hat
die landwirtschaft probleme weil sie
keinen dünger mehr hat und das nicht nur
in deutschland und das ist nur eine von
vielen folgen die wir sehen und ich
glaube die zu prognostizieren ist das
nicht schlimm wir sollten auch nicht in
die falle tappen das nur aus einer
deutschen perspektive zu diskutieren auf
der südhalbkugel beginnt gerade der
winter und wir erleben das jetzt dass
argentinien zum beispiel schwierigkeiten
hatte auf dem weltmarkt gas zu
beschaffen weil die europäer im
augenblick alles weg kaufen was noch
einen freien kapazitäten da ist dass die
preise auch auf der südhalbkugel für gas
werden in immenser höhe steigen und auch
dort bereitet man sich auf eine notlage
vor wenn man noch einen schritt weiter
geht wir haben ja in der vergangenheit
den luxus gehabt dass wir über
klimaschutz reden konnten
bei diesen gaspreisen und auch den
ölpreisen lohnen sich jetzt projekte
fossile projekte die wir eigentlich
längst beerdigt haben wollten dh wir
werden erleben dass massiv in fracking
investiert wird weltweit und und das
sind natürlich investitionen die einen
einen rattenschwanz an emissionen nach
sich ziehen für die nächsten dekaden das
klopfen wir auch gerade in die tonne was
wir eigentlich gedacht haben beim
klimaschutz erreicht zu haben also die
die sekundär wirkung eines embargos die
sollten wir nicht nur auf deutschland
und und ein paar prozent mit wachstum
mehr oder weniger fokussiert das sind ja
nicht nur ein paar prozent mit wachstum
sondern es dieser gas notfallplan von
dem haarweg jetzt die erste stufe
ausgerufen hat vergangene woche hat ja
drei stufen und in der letzten stufe
tritt dann der staat sozusagen als
verteiler 1 und da haben die
privathaushalte vor ragen die
privathaushalte und die kritische
infrastruktur und heute sind die ersten
vorsichtigen unternehmer die sagen wieso
eigentlich warum sein die
privathaushalte es ist ein sommer
frühling warum denn wir nicht also diese
diese debatte
das wort triage ist so schrecklich weil
wir es aus der kölner zeit jetzt schon
hatten aber was schalte ich ab und was
nicht wäre wenn man es mal weiter denkt
auch ein gesellschaftliches thema ich
möchte einen stratmann kurz mal wieder
reinholen sie haben jetzt gerade trias
kennen wir aus coroner zeiten ich wollte
auch mal die parallele zu corona ziehen
also wenn man sich jetzt auf diese
wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen
modellierung bezieht die sagen ja
zwischen ein und fünf prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und das ist ja
ungefähr auch so die größenordnung
gewesen wie die deutsche wirtschaft
unter corona gelitten hat jetzt könnte
man ja vereinfacht sagen na ja es hat
noch mal wie corona ja warum ist es das
nicht her strahlt manche finden ich
keine schon die grundannahme nicht weil
überhaupt er versucht das hatte petra
pinzler gerade schon angedeutet dass auf
eine nachkommastelle genau zu berechnen
in mit einem wachstumsverlust ja das
geht auf jeden fall schief das
funktioniert nicht und man muss sich
einfach der realität stellen dass der
gasnetzbetreiber der am ende entscheiden
muss ich schalte werkes oder werke y ab
um ein beispiel zu sein der weiß im
zweifel gar nicht welchen schaden er
auslöst notgedrungen weil er auch nicht
genau weiß ob der papierhersteller
berief briefpapier herstellt oder
verpackung für arzneimittel die dann
nicht mehr verpackt und gestapelt und
wie aus der logistikkette rausfahren das
ist ein schönes beispiel die folgen sind
unabsehbar und nicht vom schreibtisch
aus kalkulierbar darum ist auch der
vergleich zu dem was du eine corona
krise gesehen haben an wirtschaftlichen
einbruch nicht den kann man nicht ziehen
ist einfach nicht tauglich oder auch
sagen dass die debatte die die
kolleginnen gerade so leicht
angesprochen hat dass wir die sehr stark
kriegen werden wer am ende sparen muss
denn um nur noch ein weiteres beispiel
zu nennen tatsächlich ist es so dass
wenn man im ruhrgebiet die
stahlindustrie abstellen würde und
andere große industrien dann ist die
ganze fernwärme auch mit abgestellt das
heißt man kann gar nicht so leicht
trennen was ist denn der verbrauch der
industrie und was ist der private
verbrauch glaube warum sollen die saunen
im nächsten winter weiterlaufen aber die
industrie soll abstellen da werden wir
noch sehr genau 1 in der details nicht
aktivieren ich glaube dafür finden sich
der lösung also das was die neue
kraftwerke angeht ich komme da kann man
schon auch trennen zwischen dem
industriellen und dem restlichen bedarf
aber möglicherweise denken wir sowieso
ganz anders darüber nach weil wir
einfach preise sehen bei dem wir die
nächste heizkostenabrechnung
lieber nicht
sehen möchten welt ist einfach das ist
jenseits von gut und böse was unseren
gaspreisen droht in diesem in diesem
fall wenn auch übrigens
industrieunternehmen auch deswegen das
lässt sich auch schwer über überschlagen
der wende industrieunternehmen schon
ganz freiwillig ihre produktion
einstellen das macht diese diese ganz
preise nicht mehr durchsetzen oder auch
strompreise da lassen sie uns das ist ja
ein großes feld ich versuch's mal ein
bisschen zu strukturieren also wir sind
uns am tisch hier einig moralisch wäre
es eigentlich geboten in in anbetracht
dessen was wir an bildern aus der
ukraine sehen und was wir an sechs
wochen krieg erlebt haben aber
vernünftig pragmatisch gesprochen sagen
sie alle jetzt am tisch ein aktives öl
gas embargo gegenüber russland
macht keinen sinn vielleicht oder
vielleicht doch mit einschränkungen frau
bin sicher ich glaube man muss die
diskussion noch nur einen aspekt
erweitern nämlich nicht nur um die frage
oder vor allem nicht nur die frage wie
schadet uns das hier weil da müssen wir
immer sagen all das was wir planen zu
tun schadet uns viel weniger als das was
der ukraine im moment passiert also man
muss die maßstäbe immer im griff
behalten und ich glaube da müssten wir
deutlich mehr in kauf nehmen und da
müsste auch die bundesregierung das was
sie jetzt diese woche zumindest in form
von dem haarberg zuerst und dann nimmt
er jetzt auch angesprochen hat mehr tun
sagen leute es wird wirklich es wird
schwer und wir werden ärmer werden wir
müssen aber bei der ganzen debatte auch
im kopf haben was schadet dem putin denn
die idee ist ja nicht dass wir moralisch
gut sein wollen das leere schön sondern
die idee ist dass wir putin größtmöglich
schaden wollen und da ist für mich die
debatte um das gas häufig zu eng
fokussiert ich hab noch mal nachgeschaut
nickel kommt zu 44 prozent aus russland
aluminium um 20 palladium alle möglichen
rohstoff uran aber davon spricht in der
eu niemand weiß auch viele
osteuropäische länder betrifft oder
betreffen würden das heißt wenn die
batterien daniel auch wenn wir über im
bus nachdenken im kopf haben als immer
nur diese gas frage bei der gas frage
ist glaube ich die spur leben nachgehen
müssen würde es putin jetzt direkt
schaden oder schadet ist ihm langfristig
all die prognosen die ich kenne sagen
direkt schadet ist ihm relativ wenig
weil er seine soldaten mit rubel
bezahlen kann da brauche ich kein
ausländisches geld langfristig schadet
ist ihnen sehr viel weil er irgendwann
natürlich bestimmte technologien aus dem
ausland wird kaufen müssen dafür brauche
der wird läuft ja schon gegenmaßnahmen
also er schickt sein das war sehr
interessant außenminister lavrov der
schärfste außenpolitische waffe die die
putin besitzt war letzte woche schon in
china er war in indien und er sammelt
sozusagen die kräfte ausserhalb des
westens die durchaus bereit sind obwohl
indien größten demokratie der welt mit
ihm zusammenzuarbeiten es gab die idee
man könnte es wird das zahlungssystem
vielleicht dann doch umgehen also ich
bin mir manchmal nicht so sicher ob die
idee wenn wir jetzt alles ab tränen der
krieg morgen das ende ist
überhaupt stimmt habe ich glaube ich
noch einen satz hinzuzufügen ich glaube
die in die analyse über die wir alle
hier nicht verfügen weil wir keine
geheimdienstinformationen haben ist wird
das ein kurzer krieg würde also das
abschalten von gas putin den rest geben
oder wird es ein langer krieg und wir
müssen deswegen ein land sein bei dem
die wirtschaft noch zumindest halbwegs
funktioniert um auch der ukraine weiter
helfen zu trainieren das ist die
entscheidende frage das ist ja auch
letztlich das was er habe diese woche
sehr detailliert ausgeführt hat er würde
bei ihrem zwischen 40 gerne noch eine
einschränkung machen ich glaube schon
man muss unterscheiden zwischen pipeline
gebundenen lieferungen die gas und einem
kleinen teil des öls und jenen
lieferungen die eben nickel und der
große teil des öls und anderer rohstoffe
sich mit schiffen und ähnlichem
transportieren lassen weil da können wir
tatsächlich auch andere lieferquellen
relativ schnell erschließen und deswegen
denke ich schon dass wir bei diesen eben
nicht pipeline gebundenen rohstoffen
durchaus an einer embargo ins auge
fassen sollten als europäer und das sind
erhebliche einnahmen die russland damit
wegfielen sie machen den unterschied
jetzt weil pipeline ist halt quasi wie
autobahnen da läuft die ganze zeit der
verkehr und wenn man da auf einmal durch
trend gibt es größeres chaos als wenn
man wohl portioniert in schiffen in
containern oder sonstige rohstoffe
transportiert was jetzt die
unterscheidung diese genau und eben
dieses pipelinegas das wird dann auch
nicht woanders hin fließen das heißt es
wird ein schock am weltmarkt auslösen da
muss russland wolle ich erschließen und
um gas abfackeln das ist einfach nicht
mehr da am weltmarkt und die folgen die
das so für das für die globale ökonomie
hat die halte ich eben an der stelle zu
sein wenn sich argentinien zum beispiel
ausgeführt also dass wir da auch über
europa hinaus blicken müssen was die
pipeline rohstoffe angeht so gut dann
sagen wir jetzt mal also
ich resigniere trotzdem noch mal im
wesentlichen müssen wir zumindest bei
den pipeline rohstoffen jetzt den
gashahn proaktiv abdrehen macht keinen
sinn aus sicht der runde weil es auch
gar nicht putin sofort trifft sondern
möglicherweise wahrscheinlich
langfristig
beschädigen wird aber nicht unmittelbar
gucken wir doch mal ganz konkret zum
beispiel auf die chemische industrie sie
haben gerade schon angedeutet also die
basf als weltweit größter verbundener
standort für grundstoffe die man in
allen bereichen der industrie braucht
was würde das denn konkret also für den
fall dass es von russland jetzt kommt
das also das gras langsam runter gedreht
wird was würde das konkret für die
chemische industrie die chemische
industrie ist in hohem maße vom
russischen erdgas abhängig dass pipeline
gebundene zu uns kommt und auch nicht
leicht ersetzbar ist und auch im zweifel
gar nicht verfügbar ist im moment und
das würde an den großen standorten
innerhalb ganz kurzer zeit zu ja dazu
führen dass man den betrieb einstellen
könnte dass die anlagen heruntergefahren
werden müssten und dass die menschen
nichts zu tun hätten um es ganz platt
auszudrücken was kann was kann die
chemieindustrie tun natürlich ist sie
jetzt schon bemüht den verbrauch zu
reduzieren massiv zu reduzieren indem
man die produktion einschränkt
beispielsweise aber auch indem man die
effizienz steigert jetzt darf man sich
natürlich da keine zu großen illusionen
machen die deutsche chemische industrie
arbeitet recht effizient aus
verschiedenen gründen die auch einen
politischen hintergrund natürlich haben
und das lässt sich jetzt also nicht
beliebig fortschreiben langfristig gibt
es natürlich eine lösung man könnte
irgendwann
das gas ersetzen durch durch grünen
wasserstoff aber den gibt's auf jahre
nicht in relevanten mengen das wird noch
wahrscheinlich fünf oder zehn jahre
dauern ehe man darüber größenordnung
spricht die überhaupt wenn wir das in
zwei jahren ja gut es gibt ja ein paar
vorverträge aber wo man mal sehen aber
das ist immer noch im bereich der jetzt
nur ein bruchteil der der chemie ab der
gas abhängigkeit der chemie beseitigen
würde also großes problem für diese
branche mit und das ist heute auch hier
glaube ich schon deutlich geworden mit
immensen folgen für verwandte und für
nachgelagerte branchen die man jetzt gar
nicht auf den ersten blick sieht aber
jeder der dann kunststoff verarbeitet
oder für die pharmaindustrie wird für
ganz viele bereiche unseres täglichen
lebens selbstverständlich für die
elektronik und für die autoindustrie
werde das sofort spürbar und wir wissen
alle die lieferketten sind heute so eng
und auch ohne jeden puffer das schlägt
durch bis in das die letzte
unternehmenseinheit naja und vom
verbraucher also morgen kamen große
ketten in deutschland angekündigt was
sich die preise für lebensmittel angst
erheben und chemieindustrie bedeutet
medikamente also das sind alles der
theorie
reden wir da wird die einzelne branche
aber es kommt glaube ich bei jedem
einzelnen an und in einem maße wie herr
lindner und herwig das andeuten und der
staat wird in meinen augen im gegensatz
zur corona krise wo man das mit
kurzarbeit und so weiter versucht hat
diese folgen nicht stemmen können auch
das entlastungs paket das ist nett und
hübsch das muss jetzt auch erstmal
überhaupt beginnen noch gibt es da keine
konkreten vorgaben in den nächsten
wochen und dann ja weiß ich nicht genau
ob man die kurzarbeit ist bis ende juni
verlängert da gibt es große
befürchtungen im arbeitsministerium das
noch mal zu verlängern weil man gar
nicht wüsste was käme da ob dieses
modell zu aber es ist in der illusion
wenn man jetzt glaubt man könnte das
alles mit staatlichem geld reparieren
und über eine lange zeit ich würde
trotzdem gern haben einen anderen
tonfall mit in unserer runde bringen wir
alle wissen das wird schwer und ich
glaub wir haben das jetzt in an vielen
beispielen klar gemacht dass es
deutschland ökonomisch treffen wird und
trotzdem glaube ich liegt die
bundesregierung oder lag sie bisher
falsch mit dieser annahme dass man den
deutschen gar nichts zumuten kann denn
bisher war ja eigentlich der tenor und
der bundeskanzler glaube ich hat immer
noch redet immer noch wenn er denn
überhaupt redet so dass man alles
eigentlich nicht traut den deutschen
zusagen dass das irgendwie was mit uns
macht oder mit unserem land macht und
ich glaube da oder so wie ich das land
einschätze ist es weiter und herrn beck
hat das in der letzten woche hier sehr
sehr populär formuliert was auf uns
zukommt und dass wir uns keine
illusionen machen sondern lindner zieht
jetzt ein bisschen nach und wir werden
aber werden nur ich glaube die debatte
die jetzt folgen muss ist die frage wer
ist dieses wir wir hier am tisch werden
uns das noch ganz gut leisten können
aber was ist mit den leuten bei den
sowieso schon knapp ist die jetzt die
gasrechnung kriegen also die nächste
diskussion die wir hoffentlich führen
werden ist die um die frage wer kann
denn mehr bezahlen und wer kann weniger
bezahlen und da sind wir dann schon
gleich bei der frage muss tatsächlich
das öl das gas das benzin für alle
billiger werden so wie es die
bundesregierung jetzt plant oder wäre es
nicht besser gewesen das geld zu sparen
und es den leuten zu geben dies wirklich
dringend brauchen vielleicht eine zahl
dazu was sie gerade angesprochen haben
mitte märz hat der deutschland trend
das gefragt was wäre denn wenn wir mit
einem sofortigen energie embargo
russland gegenüber treten würden für
einen sofortigen einfuhrstopp waren 44
und 45 prozent waren dagegen also die
bevölkerung gespalten und natürlich
solche meinungen die wir da aktuell
abfragen ändern sich ja auch mit der
tatsächlichen betroffenheit die jetzt
bei jedem geldbeutel ankommt ich möchte
noch mal kurz auf die steuerung war ich
glaube dass wie viel teurer wird's was
wird wie aufgefangen werden müssen da
sind wir jetzt noch so ein bisschen im
nebel aber kurzfristig haben sie ja auch
gerade angesprochen es gibt jetzt den
gas notfallplan erste stufe also die
krisenstab einberufen man guckt jeden
tag drauf welche energie welche
industrie könnte es betreffen und so
weiter letzte stufe die
bundesnetzagentur teilt den strom dient
den gas das gras und das öl zu es gibt
aber auch auf eu ebene einen sos plan
von dem ich gelesen habe
die sos verordnung der eu bezüglich der
energieversorgung kann mir da jemand
weiterhelfen will mir sagen dass man auf
eu ebene noch tun könnte
das total interessant weil
reiche einsatz vorweg der büche nennt
wenig jetzt auch für unsere dummheit der
vergangenheit also dieser sos plan
stammt aus dem jahr 2017 war eigentlich
eine reaktion auf die krim krise oder
die creme annexion das heißt eigentlich
musst du uns schon seit jahren klar sein
was uns da droht wir haben alle die das
billige gas gerne genommen aus russland
hat auch für die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der deutschen industrie hat das auch
eine nicht unwesentliche rolle gespielt
aber eigentlich hätte man schon ahnen
können dass sich dieser dieser hebel
irgendwann auch mal in die andere
richtung bewegen könnte so und deswegen
hatte man vorsorglich in der eu eben
diese sos verordnung erlassen die auch
die grundlage ist gewissermaßen für
unsere deutschen notfallverordnung und
die sagt eben wir sind auch innerhalb
der eu solidarisch also wir sind mit
unseren bürgern solidarisch indem wir
die industrie notfalls abschalten damit
es bei denen nicht kalt wird wir sind
aber auch innerhalb der eu solidarisch
indem wir festlegen dass auch der letzte
winkel der eu noch mit gas versorgt sein
muss ehe tatsächlich auch die industrie
versorgt wird das heißt denn in der
slowakei oder bulgarien oder gegen
litauen das gas knapp wird dann werden
wir auch aus deutschland letztendlich
gasmengen frei machen müssen um diesen
dieses land zu versorgen in einer an
sicher super klingt schöner schöner
gedanke aber da sitzt auch ein
sprengsatz drin für die eu
also diese debatte die müssen wir dann
auch aushalten dass wir tatsächlich hier
dass hier leute ihre arbeit verlieren
damit in rumänien die wohnung nahmen es
wird auch deswegen extrem kompliziert
weil wir haben ja eigentlich dann ein
jahrzehnt zwei jahrzehnte der
liberalisierung der energiemärkte hinter
uns und jetzt haben wir die
bundesregierung die eigentlich in
deutschland ja schon fast die die mittel
nicht hat die muss erst mal telefonieren
bei den energieunternehmen wie viel gas
kriegt ihr denn woher und das heißt sie
fängt jetzt an in deutschland ich
überhaupt ein bild zu machen weil die
vorherigen regierung da schlicht nicht
mehr hingeguckt haben und dann muss sie
als nächsten schritt nicht nur über die
gas verteilung und die abschaltung in
deutschland möglicherweise nachdenken
sondern das ganze auch noch europäisch
koordinieren das ist nach aufgabe und es
ist übrigens auch regionale auswirkungen
in deutschland hat ich meine wir wissen
wo die nachbarn sind die am stärksten
abhängig sind das ist im südosten und
osten das heißt gas wird von dort im
zweifel abfließen und die industrie
droht also beispielsweise in bayern wird
sich schwerer versorgen lassen als die
im westen die traditionell an
norwegischen oder niederländischen
gaslieferungen an dieses
nord-süd-gefälle denkt man hier in der
deutschen debatte ja auch nicht die
bayerische wirtschaft macht da immer
wieder darauf aufmerksam aber das wird
dann auch sehr deutlich und das auch nur
dann wird dann wird also auch innerhalb
deutschlands eine verteilungsdiskussion
in der wirtschaft losgehen die ich auch
gar nicht gerne erleben will aber die
unausweichlich ist zitieren sie erklären
sie noch mal was ihr jetzt mit nord süd
und ost
innerhalb deutschlands ist die
gasversorgung nicht etwa völlig
harmonisch ausgeglichen sondern es gibt
aufgrund der pipeline verbindung und der
übergabe punkte die jetzt nicht die an
bestimmten stellen der landesgrenze
neben sind eben auch nicht ganz
gleichmäßige verteilung situationen das
ist einfach physikalisch technisch so
und das wird dazu könnte dazu führen
dass eben im süden deutschlands die lage
in bayern insbesondere am ende
angespannter sein wird als in anderen
teilen des landes besser angebunden
sowohl über 100 als auch über pipelines
nicht unbedingt also osten haben wir das
problem dass der osten steht zum
beispiel das öl aus dieser pipeline die
aus russland kommt bekommt und wenn die
abgestellt wird dann haben wir im osten
die probleme habe es vorhin erwähnt in
berlin fliegt jetzt haben wir mal kurz
öl und gas noch vermisst aber egal dass
genau das ist der punkt in
ostdeutschland wenn die diese druschba
pipeline nicht mehr wenn man da die mit
einem embargo verlegt wenn das russische
öl dadurch also nicht mehr strömt dann
ist die dann fährt kein feuerwehrwagen
und hebt in ostdeutschland und fliegt
auch kein lebt auch kein flugzeug in
einer besseren welt würde aber diese
ganze geschichte danone wenn man diesen
krieg
ausblenden kann man ihn gar nicht aber
die idee dass diese energiewende was
bringt gerade weil die bayern sagt
markus söder der ja mit herrn habe ich
immer über kreuz liegt wie das mit dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren jetzt so
vorangehen soll und also die idee glaube
ich um mal irgendwas positives
rauszuziehen das dass es eine
energiewende braucht in diesem land und
zwar nicht irgendwann sondern sofort
ich glaube die ist auch über alle
politischen grenzen hinweg weiter
vorgedrungen genau ich wollte jetzt auch
in die positive runde kommen sie haben
es ja eben auch schon angedeutet also
einerseits ist diese ampel regierung ja
angetreten die regierung der
erneuerbaren zu sein des klimaschutzes
und überhaupt und sieht sich jetzt
realpolitisch in der situation dass man
möglicherweise erst mal wieder mehr
kohle verbrennen muss
möglicherweise gas in der nordsee
fördern muss was man sich eigentlich
alles überhaupt nicht mehr gewünscht hat
möglicherweise über kernkraftwerke
diskutieren auch wenn das vielleicht
alles gar keinen sinn macht ich greife
ihren gedanken gerne auf also kann man
daraus jetzt eine positive energie
gewinnen um eben diesen wandel
fortzuschreiben in die erinnert er
erneuerbaren energien hin hat georg
maier auch auf youtube gefragt bei der
verteidigung hat man schnell reagiert
mit den 100 milliarden sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr warum gibt es jetzt
nicht 100 milliarden für die
erneuerbaren energien und andere nutzer
gehen in die ähnliche richtung warum
jetzt nicht mit voller kraft
investieren in nachhaltige energie
energiegewinnung das möchte ich jetzt
mal so also ich glaube für die zukunft
ich glaube da ist ist ja sind die
weichen gestellt es wird jetzt ein das
sogenannte roster paket der
bundesregierung verabschiedet das hat
zum inhalt dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien
enorm beschleunigt wird und es werde ein
weiteres paket im sommer noch folgen
also man ebnet den weg für einen starken
schnellen ausbau der erneuerbaren und
jetzt ist eben der punkt auch wenn man
möchte dass dieser ausbau sich noch
wesentlich schneller vollzieht es gibt
praktisch technische grenzen
wir haben jetzt das ziel das steht schon
im koalitionsvertrag und das hat mit
dieser ukraine katastrophe nichts zu tun
dass zwei prozent der landesfläche für
den windkraftausbau zur verfügung
gestellt werden sollen dass das wird so
kommen wahrscheinlich und
das lässt sich aber nicht beliebig
vervielfältigen und sind auch
kapazitätsprobleme man kann nicht
beliebig viele viel megawatt leistung
windkraft zu bauen das ist es ist ein
flaschenhals es ist nicht so skalierbar
wie man es jetzt gerne hätte und man
kann den hebel eben nicht mit einem mal
um aber diese debatte führen sind
natürlich jetzt ganz neu ja also bisher
haben wir immer über klimaschutz und
schöne grüne erneuerbare energien
gesprochen jetzt reden wir über
unabhängigkeit also dass das fremd die
ganze debatte neu also ich weiß nicht
wie ein markus söder jetzt diese 10h
regel noch aufrechterhalten will also es
geht jetzt wirklich
tagen kurz mal die 10 h regel was das
genau ist eine abstandsregel die
vorschreibt dass der abstand einer
siedlung rund um ein windrad des
zehnfachen der höhe betragen muss also
das macht in weiten teilen bayerns
eigentlich den ausbau der windenergie
zunichte und und all diese debatten die
ja auch die koalition schon vor diesen
krieg geführt hatte über die frage wie
können wir naturschutz regeln
harmonisieren die wie können wir das
verfahren insgesamt beschleunigen also
die die werden jetzt in einem alt empor
durchgepeitscht wie wir das lange nicht
erlebt haben also natürlich würde man
sich wünschen dass jetzt genau in diesen
100 milliarden denen die verteidigung
fließen auch in die erneuerbare fliessen
aber sie könnten ebenso schnell gar
nicht so viel bewirken und auf der
anderen seite sehen wir auch strompreise
in rekordhöhe die natürlich auch
erneuerbaren energien zugute kommen also
die rechnungen werden jetzt ganz anders
gemacht bei denen bei den betreibern der
lohnt sich vielmehr der ausbau als wir
das bisher getan als würde sagen wenn
wir alles zusammen zählen sind wir fast
100 milliarden auch bei dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren was aber glaube ich noch
was zählen sie da alles zu werden na ja
all die förderung die jetzt dann für
mehr energieeffizienz bekommen beim
ausbau oder dämmen der häuser
bei der erneuerung der heizung das
kostet ja alles irrsinnig viel geld und
bei der förderung der elektromobilität
das ist teuer aber es macht sinn und das
interessante aber auch mir dann ich habe
vorhin unterhalten dass wir über klima
und energiewende ja tatsächlich schon
lange schreiben inzwischen interessieren
sich aber auch kollegen die bisher über
über über sicherheit gesprochen und
geschrieben haben weil wir energie
sicherheit und klimawende oder
energiewende jetzt auf einmal zusammen
denken und da konvergiert was und wenn
wir das versuchen positiv zu drehen dann
kann in diesem land tatsächlich dann mit
einem tempo was freigesetzt werden sie
haben in allen zeitungen jetzt darüber
artikel darüber wann es sinn macht eine
wärmepumpe einzubauen die leute denken
über das heißt über die förderungen ist
auf einmal das tempo ihrer fenster nach
wer sein fenster dem tut was gegen putin
so kann man es tatsächlich aber keine
café förderung mehr wenn die tausende
euro an gasrechnung zahlen das wird also
noch mal ganz neue motivation auslösen
tatsächlich auch gebäude zudem weil es
einfach jetzt ein problem ist dass sie
schwarz auf weiß auf rechnung nachlesen
lässt also da kommen wir in eine andere
welt
ich hoffe nur dass ähnlich wie bei einer
ölkrise in den 70er jahren ja auch ein
umdenken in sachen energieeffizienz
geachtet dass wir aus dieser aus dieser
diese auch eine eine erfahrung mitnehmen
und nicht in zwei jahren wenn
möglicherweise die gaspreise wieder
gefallen sind genau ich wollte den
optimismus kurz mal mit hier drüben
spielen
prinzip dabei alles richtig aber es gibt
eben jetzt schon entschuldigung es gab
schon vor der ukraine krise die
hilferufe aus bestimmten branchen
das ist überhaupt gar nicht mehr genug
leute gibt und um das überhaupt
auszuführen was auch zu
dass man auch finden müsste es gibt
nicht genug leute eigentlich genug
planungs und genehmigungsphase denton
das lässt sich alles beschleunigen und
entbürokratisieren hoffe ich jedenfalls
man kommt aber nicht beliebig weit damit
dass man wird die sechs millionen
wärmepumpen bis 2030 nicht mal eben
verbauen können ja das ist alles
schwierig wird das wissen wir ja wir
können mit diesem land oder gar nicht
nur in diesem land mit europa vielleicht
mit der welt in eine von einer krise in
die nächste und die krisen verstärken
sich corona verstärkt die krise die wir
auf die finanzkrise dass die klimakrise
wird verstärkt durch das was wir jetzt
durch diesen fürchterlichen krieg
erleben also die die zukunft düster
zumal glaube ich fällt uns alle allen
heutzutage unglaublich einfach die frage
ist doch wo können wir die vielen
kleinen schritte gehen die
möglicherweise auch viele leute
motivieren was zu verändern und ich
glaube da ist die idee von von meinem
kollegen war auch müller die ja gar
nicht nur seine ist dass wir dass wir
energie sparen können das wir einsparen
das was habe ich mit dem motiv sagt dass
das vielleicht auch mal weniger werden
kann das ist glaube ich schon der
richtige weg auf jeden fall dann kann
die temperatur ein bisschen runter dem
haus das kann jeder sollte auch jeder
machen ob das so ausreichend es reicht
ja auch keiner klar aber es wird eben
nicht so leicht fallen diesen riesigen
transformationsprozess den wir jetzt
noch beschleunigen müssen auch praktisch
um das gibt es probleme natürlich ist
fehlen einfach zum beispiel um geht's
mal auf die schnelle ganz viele häuser
zu sanieren
aber ich meine seit seit jahren fast
jahrzehnten reden wir so viel über die
vorbehalte über die hemden ist dieses
geht nicht und jeden es geht mich ja weg
beschreibt das immer mit seiner
bräsigkeit
ich glaube dass diese krise jetzt die
chance ist tatsächlich einige dieser
vorbehalte und hindernisse mal hinter
uns zu lassen und tatsächlich darüber
nachzudenken wie sich dinge
beschleunigen lassen es geht jetzt immer
das wort das möglicherweise
sanitärinstallateur weniger bäder
sanieren und stattdessen eben weniger
eben mehr einbauküchen der solarzellen
oder mehr häuser den ja wahrscheinlich
müssen wir in solchen neuen prioritäten
kommen ja aber die chance besteht jetzt
aber ich habe es doch richtig verstanden
oder ich bin ja freue mich über ihren
optimismus also tatsächlich wird die
ganze debatte jetzt neu geformt und man
hat eine neue notwendigkeit umzustellen
die ganze wirtschaft aber ich habe
gelesen wir wollen bis sommer 24 uns von
russischem gas unabhängig machen das
wäre jetzt also in knapp zweieinhalb
jahren und ich habe es bislang so
verstanden dass dafür der ausbau der
erneuerbaren gar nicht reichen würde
weil den strom den man damit erzeugt ja
nicht den mangel von gas kompensieren
kann das ist doch richtig also wird man
noch was dazu machen müssen und das
läuft ja auch gerade man wird das ganz
woanders her holen und habe mich bemüht
sich ja sehr auf allen ebenen das auch
zu forcieren in einen in allen ländern
zb in katar wie neulich aber auch in den
usa in norwegen am montag trifft seinen
niederländischen amtskollegen da ja auch
ein wichtiges gas export land darstellt
vertritt und außerdem wird es natürlich
darum gehen deutschland fit zu machen
für den lng importe also für den import
von verflüssigtem erdgas das wir bislang
nicht selbst importieren können am ende
war was ist ich musste vorhin schmunzeln
ja litauen hat und lng terminal da kann
man jetzt sagen wir wollen kein
russisches gas mehr dieses terminal ist
zu 65 prozent ausgelastet man kann mit
mit den restlichen kapazitäten die da
sind dann das russische gas ersetzen das
setzen das können wir nicht wir sind
darauf angewiesen dass über rotterdam
oder aus berlin zu importieren da gibt
es kapazitätsengpässe die infrastruktur
ist nicht unendlich erweiterbar
also ist das jetzt absolut vordringlich
und es wäre natürlich ein trumpf den wir
in der hand halten wenn es gelänge bis
ende des jahres vor beginn des oder mit
beginn des kommenden winters
einschwimmen des lng terminal mindestens
1 oder vielleicht zwei in deutschland zu
haben es gibt es gibt vorsichtige
hoffnung dass das gelingen kann dass wir
absoluter
kraftakt und das wird auch schwierig das
anzuwenden aber
okay das ja ich viel aktionismus stil
die regie dieser run auf lng terminals
weil wir haben europaweit haben wir zwei
dutzend dieser termin aber sie sind in
letzter zeit ausgelastet einige von
ihnen sind jetzt ausgelastet aber es ist
ich glaube nicht dass uns das
versicherungspolice wir wie wir sind
jetzt gerade wo es offensichtlich noch
mal sehr emotional bei den allen die
flüssiggas terminals wird am ende der
sendung dieser sendung angelangt ich
glaube wir haben aber gleich noch in der
nächsten viertelstunde die chance und
das weiter zu diskutieren weil phoenix
und wdr 5 gibt es nämlich presseclub
nachgefragt wenn sie aber hier im ersten
bleiben wollen geht es weiter mit dem
europamagazin und markus preis der unter
anderem der frage nachgeht warum der
serbische präsident muss sich trotz des
russischen angriffskriegs immer noch in
der nähe von putin aufhält egal auf
welchem kanal sie weitermachen ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen guten sonntag
und danke für ihr interesse
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder bei wdr 5 und
phoenix mit presseclub nachgefragt zum
thema ohne putins öl und gas welche
folgen drohen uns und ich möchte gerne
gleich als erstes zu peter volk nach
todtnau gehen guten tag und ihre frage
an die runde bitte hallo und schönen
guten tag ich freue mich dass ich
durchgekommen bin ich will meine ganzen
einen ganz neuen aspekt vielleicht
zuerst mal vielleicht ein bisschen
argumentieren dass sich die frage und
zwar dieser aspekt ist jetzt müssen wir
also die us visa zwischen pest und
cholera und sind bevölkerung geteilt
wann sollen wir nicht nach dem prinzip
gehen lieber ein schrecken mit ende also
1 1 ein ende mit schrecken als ein
schrecken ohne ende und zwar durch eine
volksabstimmung
grundsätzlich
volksabstimmung auf bundesebene
gemäss artikel 20 absatz 2 und wenn sie
mir nicht anders möglich ist der vater
habe ich ein argument für doktor
heribert prantl
geschätzte kollegin der rang 1 über
diese sache geschrieben hat süddeutsche
zeitung am 26 juni 2012 damals wollte
die spd folgt im august nehmen zu lassen
und jetzt ist dieses argument könnte
wenn nicht der fall in der
bundestagsdebatte hat man nicht über die
ursachen diskutiert und weil sich die
politiker verschätzt haben aber dafür in
so einer schwierigen abhängige com
hervor sollen wir wieder die politiker
fielen
wieder dass sie abschätzen dass das volk
sozusagen meer zu leiten hat ihre
beschwere
abwägungsfrage
sollte man durfte deutschen vorreiter
sogar dem europäischen folgen und ihre
fragen
müsse man werde meine
danke erfolg und ihre frage ist wie
gesagt kann man nicht eine
volksabstimmung über einen energie
embargo
entstehen lassen und frau münstermann
wenn sie mögen dürfen sie antworten die
ich finde die frage berechtigt und das
ist eine sache die wir aus geführt haben
das ganze land betrifft bin aber ein
ganz großer anhänger der repräsentativen
demokratie die wir ja in diesem land
haben und deswegen haben wir ein
bundestag wir haben eine exekutive und
wir haben eine legislative und ich finde
dass genau dafür die menschen gewählt
wurden dass es ihre aufgabe
der bundestag muss entscheiden die
regierung muss das ausführen und
deswegen halte ich das für keinen guten
weg
danke für diese antwort dann möchte ich
gerne zu klaus borchert nach börsen
gehen guten tag und was möchten sie
gerne frage
ob man hier
folgendes mir geht vorgesehen koch ich
bin für pragmatismus
pragmatismus wir unterstützen die
ukraine wo immer wir können also auf
jeden fall medizin ist mit den menschen
mit ihm aufnehmen mit allen möglichen
was wir bauen vielleicht lazarette und
bompas auch hier bei uns werden wir
sehen wie neue infrastruktur brauchen
flüchtlinge länger hier bleiben braucht
man wirklich neue wohnungen das ist das
eine von mir aus können wir auch waffen
in die ukraine liefern das andere ist
wir nehmen noch in schweigen betrieb wir
nehmen das ganze chaos und auch die
rohstoffe aus russland und machen damit
hier bei uns die wende die wir brauchen
weil wir brauchen die rohstoffe kommen
ohne die überhaupt nicht über die unten
also ich habe zum beispiel haben jetzt
übrigens medikament jetzt nicht beziehen
können jetzt schon
jetzt eines beispiel so da kommen wir
nicht vorbei an der erkenntnis im ersten
weltkrieg waren die englischen granaten
mit zündern von aufgerüstet hat sich
keiner drüber aufgeregt also wir fahren
zweigleisig wir halten unsere
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu russland auch
recht was auch sicherlich für uns von
vorteil ist und auch einen gewissen
einfluss und sichert und machen damit
unsere energiewende weil wir brauchen
für 20.000
windkraftanlagen unmengen an kupfer
aluminium welten den erben für kupfer
palladium mit neodym und das sei das
unesco bald zwei jahre jung war noch
dazu gehört ja und das ist nur ein ganz
kleiner teil respekt okay also werden
wir wirklich verkraftet er will herr
borchert entschuldigung das heißt also
ihr plädoyer wäre pragmatisch einerseits
wirtschaftsbeziehung so gut es geht zu
russland aufrechterhalten sind ja
durchaus schon eingeschränkt trotzdem
zwei ist immer nicht in betrieb aber sie
sagen wir brauchen das um bei uns die
wende zu schaffen wollen sind darauf
verantworten sehr gerne
ich glaube also nord stream zwei jetzt
in betrieb zu nehmen das wäre ein schlag
ins gesicht aber der ukraine und würde
von keinem unserer verbündeten und
partner verstanden werden also dass das
würde ich nicht empfehlen was ihr aber
ansprechend ist natürlich unsere
abhängigkeit von gas ist da und auch für
die energiewende brauchen wir ganz ganz
klar einfach auch weil es sich sehr
leicht an und abfahren lässt in
kraftwerken und damit ein guter partner
ist eigentlich für die erneuerbaren
energien die er relativ volatilen
aufschließen das heißt ja wir werden
weiterhin gas brauchen aber nein wir
sollten jetzt deswegen nicht noch
weitere wege aus russland auf machen
sondern uns tatsächlich danach um sehen
wie diese energiewende daneben auf
darauf funktionieren kann mit gas aus
anderen staaten und und die vorbereitung
darauf laufen und das halte ich auch für
richtig
danke dann gehen wir jetzt nach hessen
zu mark hamill ortenberg und ich würde
mich über ihre frage freuen hallo
hallo mit und ich würde mal
interessieren ich bin besitzer einer
elektro hype würden auch nicht mal
drüber nachgedacht werden soll unsere
atommeiler zum jahresende abzuschalten
weil strom ist auch ein energieträger
und wir brauchen
energie auch strom gas oder kohle das
heißt ihre frage wäre die drei meiler
die jetzt verbleiben eben nicht zum ende
22 abzuschalten sondern länger am netz
zu lassen herr stratmann wollen sie
darauf antworten ja kann ich versuchen
also meine meinung ist die ich bin da
eher skeptisch sie haben natürlich recht
wir können den strom aller art gut
gebrauchen und gerade auch die
gesicherte leistung die solche
atomkraftwerke liefern aber die ich
glaube der zug ist abgefahren die
betreiber selbst bis auf eine ausnahme
da kann man gleich noch ein sagt darüber
verlieren sind nicht dazu bereit und
werden haben alle weichen so gestellt
sich damit abzufinden dass die
betriebsgenehmigung ihrer anlagen am
31.12 ausläuft jetzt die passende
konfektionierten brennstäbe noch zu
bekommen und alles weitere genehmigungs
und rechtliche zu organisieren und vor
allen dingen auch die die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen vorzuführen das
haben die unternehmen gar nicht mehr in
der kalkulation und auch die die
personalsituation gibt das nicht her
also insgesamt bin ich da sehr skeptisch
ob das funktioniert jetzt hat es neulich
einen brief gegeben eines betreibers der
war so zu deuten als sei da doch die
bereitschaft das müsste man noch mal
genauer prüfen insgesamt habe ich aber
aus der branche eher verstanden dass sie
es gar nicht machen wollen sich also zum
jagen tragen lassen müssten das sind
auch sehr schlechte voraussetzungen
glaube ich
danke und vor allem braucht man auch da
wieder gewisse rohstoffe die man unter
umständen auch wieder aus russland dann
importieren müsste ich möchte jetzt
gerne ich bleibe in hessen bei sophia
pfitzner in frankfurt guten tag und ihre
frage bitte guten tag mein name ist
sieht man ich bin eine treue
kunden von ihm loszusagen und ich habe
eine frage an alle
an alle journalisten die das sitzen mein
problem ist sicher die heuchelei
wir haben die moral hochgestellt
alles was privat ist nicht
demokratischen blablabla aber wie genial
katar und wollen wir da sein außerdem
demokratischen laden mit menschenrechten
akzeptiert nein
zum krieg die smarten freihändig wer ist
gut ankomme auskommen wird da werden
menschen sterben jährlich interessiert
uns auch nicht gleich unsere
moralvorstellung 0 ich hätte gern am
ärmel
familienkirche
lively ist komplett produzentin frau
pfitzner danke
seinen zwei das gleiche tun ist dasselbe
meinem ein problem er verstanden wie
medien sie ist die felgen ein volk ohne
ende
wiki haben unsere moralvorstellung dach
hoch da wo wir
jemanden am boden
ich versuche es mal zusammenzufassen sie
sagen einerseits natürlich das
moralische problem wie wir seit 20
jahren mit russland umgegangen sind wo
man ja schon sehen konnte möglicherweise
was sich jetzt realisiert hat und
andererseits gehen wir jetzt nach katar
auch ein land was durchaus
menschenrechtsprobleme hat frau pinzler
die heuchelei der deutschen politik ich
kann haben die nach wien fliegen ja auch
noch die arabien gegen
geben erstens poppins antworten danke
frau plötzlich ich kann ihnen nur
zustimmen ich teile ihre gefühle gefühl
ich finde auch dass wir uns für manche
ist das ja da getan haben schämen müssen
es ist nicht richtig wenn wir ich glaub
der wirtschaftsminister hat gesagt wäre
würden wir tragen eine spur der
verwüstung durch durch diese welt
ungefähr so und das ist völlig richtig
die art und weise das modell das wir
leben ist schlecht für die umwelt ist es
schlecht für viele menschen ist
verpflichtet unser zu rohstoffe aus
ländern zu importieren die die
menschenrechte mit den füßen treten und
trotzdem der wirtschaftsminister hat
gesagt wenn man in der politik macht man
sich die hände schmutzig ein bisschen
glaube ich ist das davon das ist alles
im moment nicht gut und es gibt
eigentlich moment nur schlechte lösungen
die beste ist tatsächlich und die lässt
sich aber eben kurzfristig ohne massive
verwerfungen nicht durchsetzen dass wir
unseren rohstoffbedarf und unseren
ressourcen fahrradfahrt bedarf in dieser
welt massiv reduzieren darauf wird es
hinauslaufen
danke dann können wir mal in nordrhein
westfalen bleiben bei unfall hof kramer
in detmold hallo und was möchten sie
gerne die runde fragt ja guten platz
dann ja wir leben ja jetzt auch wirklich
tragische weise wie er diese banken
wichtige und für rückwärtsgewandte
politik energiepolitik der vergangenen
regierung merkel wie eben die
energiewende immer wieder ausgebremst
passt dass die ambitioniert
weiterzuführen und unabhängig zu machen
wie er das unserem land jetzt schadet
und alleine unter klima aspekten hätten
seien würden denn dass die macht liegt
uns um die ohren und wir haben nur noch
eine ganz kurze zeit um zu erreichen
dass neben der klimawandel und komplett
entgleitet und einfach unterricht
grundlagen zerstört und ich möchte dir
mal die frage stellen wie kann es sein
dass eine fdp dass ein herr lindner aus
ideologischen gründen nicht jeder
wildunfall weiter nun ganz gut einem
cent positiv zum beispiel autofreien
sonntagen dass die nicht bereit sind
auch in dieser notsituation
erreicht die in diesem land an denen an
den problemen an den gesetzlichen
notwendigkeiten an den finanzmärkten zu
beteiligen um geschafft nicht nur ein
klassisches die hohen energiepreise
durch das belastet das nicht hindert
nicht eine unsolidarische und wirklich
asoziale politik herr alois kramer
vielen danke für diese frage die
teilweise eine meinung war sie beziehen
sich ja jetzt auch auf die 70er jahre
während der ölkrise gab es ja autofreie
sonntage und ähnliches sie haben das
tempolimit angesprochen wer möchte sich
dazu äußern da hatte man also was sie
sagen ist natürlich eine eine politik
die herr lindner vor allem für seine
wählerklientel macht das sind viele
unternehmen die fdp hat sich auch in der
korona politik als freiheitspartei
hervorgetan und für die fdp sind sachen
wie autofreier sonntag tempolimit
einschränkungen dieser freiheit so nehme
ich das war aber es wird die debatte
geben die grünen-chefin ricarda lang hat
sehr massiv jetzt in einem interview am
wochenende auf ein tempo limit bis zum
ende des jahres gedrungen und es ist
eine ampel regierung es sind spd grüne
und fdp und ich glaube genau die debatte
wird zwischen grünen und fdp ganz groß
werden und ich bin sehr gespannt wie und
ob kanzler scholz das dann moderieren
kann eigentlich sehr vulgär ökonomischer
sicht auf die freiheiten die wir da so
erleben
vielleicht haben wir noch die zeit weil
wir ja auch dem ende unserer sendungen
uns nähern ich würde gerne noch eugen
sora schewski fragen aus bergisch
gladbach
guten tag
[Musik]
nachbarin 540 vergewaltigung sklaverei
und alles alles ist so ähnlich wie jetzt
meine frage ist warum deutschland bei
umgang mit putin wenig auf osteuropa und
ich habe meistens
präsidenten kaczynski des flugzeugs
2008 sagte schon heute georgien als er
hat reagiert er morgen ukraine späten
baltikum länder und vielleicht dann
meine land polen aber keiner hat aber
gehört immer polen war okay ich hab auch
gesagt wegen nach dem 10 und auch die
deutsche zeitung war immer befreundet
und wenn es die große liebe die schüler
mit putin
deutsch-russischer lieber später kommt
immer europa kraft wunder dass vor mir
meine frage mehr kontakte mehr
marco auf alles kultur sport und drei
jahre wie deutschland damals bis 54 weit
fußball internationalen er ist erst auf
ski damit jetzt jemand noch auf diese
frage antworten kann also ich habe aus
gehört warum hat die deutsche politik so
wenig auf die osteuropäischen
nachbarländer gehört unter anderem auch
auf ihr heimatland auf polen und weil
die süddeutsche zeitung angefahren wurde
herr brauchten wieder bitte sehr gerne
ich komme dass sie enttäuscht von der sz
aber das ist ein anderes thema ich
glaube dass die deutschen sehr sehr
lange geglaubt haben und eigentlich
angefangen in den 70er jahren dass man
durch den handel eben auch annäherung
erzeugt und damit eigentlich russland
auch mehr länger binden kann und das
führt eigentlich bis in die heutige zeit
hinein dieser glaube der ist jetzt
endgültig erschüttert worden und von
daher glaube ich dass das verhältnis zu
russland wird ein anderes sein zurück
leider er braucht nur das sie hören ist
wir spielen die musik ein denn wir sind
am ende dieses nachgefragt dass
presseclub angekommen ich bedanke mich
für die engagierte diskussion bei ihnen
bei ihnen zuhause für ihr interesse ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen guten kontakt
[Musik]